it's part of mankind to want to explore
you are tremendously curious about the
world and we want to understand it
better
you can't turn yourself off
[Music]
I want to be able to go into any kind of
environment work with any kind of people
we realize that there were people
building structures and altitudes of
having to move reached until those 400
years later what's unusual about the
Andes is it's one of the few places in
the world where you can get bytom's so
well preserved that many of them can
look like they're new and that includes
frozen mummies
these mummies are virtually perfectly
preserved so there is literally a real
time capsule
[Music]
because solve problems that Mountaineers
didn't sell until 14 years later so they
were way ahead of their time certainly
the first climbers the reason that we
studied high-altitude archaeology might
so important is to see this kind of link
with the past
in a very young age I saw myself as an
explorer and I'm never going to stop
trying to solve mysteries
[Music]